this whale of a tale involves a super
sleuth named Ken Falco spies on killer
whales in the American state of
Washington using this really
high-powered telescope he also drops
microphones in the water so he can hear
what they're up to let's listen in yep
that's killer whale lingo it's a very
difficult language for humans to
understand some people study it for
years and knows all the gang members by
sight this pod is led by a real
character goes by the name of granny she
may be more than 90 years old but one
morning in met can encounter them very
steering
suddenly a group of porpoises start
racing out of carrying the grannies clan
heads towards Shore but they're going to
swim on to the beach why are these
marine mammal connecting so great you
can spot an important clue there's a US
Navy ship nearby and it's sending out
sonar waves ships your sonar map out
what's under the water they send out a
wave of sound that bounces back on
objects that's how they know what's down
there sonar is really loud oh that hurts
my ears Kent suspects is turning to
killer whales ears too yeah whales have
ears even if they don't stick out from
the heads like ours too well like mine
and remember their whale talk it's how
they communicate with each other they
have to have pretty sensitive ears to
hear each other under water from miles
and miles away anyway can notify the
Navy as quickly as possible and the
sonar is turned off here great detective
work by Ken and other agents has shown
that sonar can really hurt whales
especially the really powerful so far
used by naval ships when blasted with
underwater noise some whales try to get
their heads out of water and others
become confused and swim in all
directions some even swim out of the
water cold stranded that's weird
dangerous for the whale the baby is now
aware that they need to be extra careful
where they use sonar to protect nearby
whales
so this is a case of good detective work
and it's helping out animals like granny
inter-gang
ah finally
hi